on a tous des héritages des héritages
personnels qui guident nos engagements
et qui doivent normalement guider les
raisons qui font que nous avons eu envie
de devenir parlementaire de nous exposer
et de solliciter le suffrage des
Français la question du combat des
droits des femmes de leur liberté de
leur émancipation a toujours été au cœur
des combats que j'ai menés avant de
revenir dans cette hémicique puisque je
n'ai pas tout à fait prévu d'être là cet
après-midi j'ai appelé une seule
personne qui se trouve être ma maman et
si je vous parle d'elle c'est parce
qu'elle m'a donné l'autorisation de le
faire ma mère a eu recours à
l'avortement à un moment où c'était
illégal dans notre pays
elle y a eu recours comme peut-être un
certain nombre de nos maires de nos
grand-mères elle y a eu recours dans un
moment où elle risquait la prison et
elle risquait sa vie où elle a d'abord
fait appel à un médecin
vraisemblablement assez connu à l'époque
pour cela mais l'opération ne s'est pas
très bien passée
et comme pour de trop nombreuses femmes
elle a dû ensuite aller à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital où elle pensait trouver un
refuge un refuge bienveillant un refuge
accueillant elle a été reçue sous une
forme d'inquisition parce qu'on avait
bien compris évidemment l'acte qu'elle
avait tenté de réaliser à ce moment là
et alors alors qu'elle était dans les
mains de médecins et bien ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est qu'elle a en
effet pu mettre un terme à sa grossesse
mais qu'elle a subi un curetage sans
anesthésie voilà ce qui se passait voilà
ce que les femmes subissaient voilà ce
que nos maires ont pu subir voilà ce que
nos grands-mères ont pu subir la
question de l'accès à l'IVG la question
de sa protection c'est pas un caprice
c'est pas un gain politique c'est pas
une question de groupe politique les
Français on a cessé de le dire ici ont
d'ailleurs fait en sorte que nous ayons
une nouvelle assemblée et que nous
arrivions à démontrer que nous pouvions
travailler différemment c'est sur la
question des droits des femmes nous ne
sommes pas capables de le faire alors
nous serons capables de le faire sur
aucun texte et je crois que c'est la
démarche qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui
alors je le dis très clairement et très
nettement le texte que nous nous
apprêtons à voter et je l'espère avec la
plus large majorité possible aujourd'hui
ce texte là devient le texte de notre
assemblée devient le texte qui doit
toutes et tous nous réunir devient le
texte qui doit pouvoir aboutir parce que
nous ne devons pas finir notre mandat de
parlementaire sans que notre
Constitution ait été modifiée sans que
l'IVG ait été intégré à notre
Constitution c'est ça l'engagement que
nous devons prendre c'est ça
l'engagement que nous prenons
aujourd'hui en votant ce texte
en votant ce texte qui sera le texte
unique sur ce sujet alors je le dis de
manière claire
au nom de toutes les femmes au nom de
toutes nos mères qui se sont battues au
nom de toutes nos filles qui n'ont plus
jamais à devoir se battre je l'espère
oui je suis ici pour cela pour voter ce
texte et j'espère qu'il sera voté de
manière très large aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]